هذه الصور المباشره من تجمع المستوطنين في
منطقه جنوب نابلس ادانا ببدا هذه المسيره
اذا التي طيب وايضا نشاهد في الصور بوزير
الامن الداخلي اثمار الذي وصل الى هذه
المنطقه للمشاركه ربما في هذه المسيره
التي تنطلق من هذا المكان
بتوجها الى جبل صبيح في بلده بيتا هذه
المنطقه التي تطالب المنظمات اليهوديه
الداعمه الاستيطان بشرعنتها في بؤره
ابيتار الايطاليه نعود اليك عبد الحفيظ
ماذا نعرف اكثر حول هذه المسيره توجهاتها
المطالب ايضا التي تتبناها هذه المنظمات
احمد انا على الطرف الاخر لان يعني
للصحافه الفلسطينيه لم يسمح لنا الاقتراب
اكثر من المستوطنين وبالتالي نحن قباله
جبل صبيح هذا هو الجبل الذي يجري الحديث
عنه وهذه هي مستوطنه افيتار هذا اقرب مكان
استطعنا الوصول اليه من الناحيه الاخرى من
الجبل كما تشاهد في الصوره هناك المئات من
المستوطنين الان
بداوا بالصعود نحو مستوطنه افيتار او جبل
صبيح كما يفضل الفلسطينيون تسميته
العشرات من المنظمات الاستيطانيه سبعه
وزراء من الحكومه الاسرائيليه منهم وزير
الامن القومي
بنجافير وايضا وزير الماليه وغيرهم من
اعضاء البرلمان الاسرائيلي ايضا يشاركون
في هذه التظاهره التي تحاول الضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لشرعنه هذه البؤره الاستيطانيه
السماح للمستوطنين اليهود
بالبناء فيها
على اليمين قليلا يعني يمكن ان تشاهد او
تتحدث هذه البيوت المتنقله عن قصه هذا
الجبل قبل ان تحديدا قبل ثلاثه اعوام قام
المستوطنون بالاتيان بمباني متنقله
ووضعوها على هذا الجبل وقاموا باحتلاله
وضعوا عليه نجمه داوود كبرى واقاموا عليه
بيوتا وقرروا بناء مستوطنه لكن تبين ان
الاراضي هي اراضي اراضي دوله واراضي خاصه
للفلسطينيين وبالتالي صدر قرار من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه باخلاء هذه المستوطنه
المستوطنون احتجوا بشكل كبير وكان هناك
تسويه بين الحكومات الاسرائيليه السابقه
والمستوطنين باخلاء المستوطنين ولكن ابقاء
منازلهم على قمه هذه الجبل محروسه بقوات
من الجيش الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذه المسيره
تعود الى هذه المنازل في اطار الضغط لسماح
للمستوط نين باعاده اعمارها واعادتها
لماذا تمت اثاره هذا الملف في هذا التوقيت
تحديدا يعني هل للتوقيت الان اي دلالات
منذ قدوم هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه تم
شرعنا الثمان بؤر الاستيطانيه مثل هذه
بضغط من
وزير الامن القومي اعتمار بنجافير وايضا
وزير الماليه وممثلون الصهيونيه الدينيه
وهم اصلا اتوا الى الحكومه باجندا
استيطانيه وممثلين على الاستيطان و
مدعومين من الاستيطان وبالتالي هذه تقريبا
جزء كبير من اجنده الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه حكومه نتنياهو هي هذه البؤره
الاستيطانيه وشرعنتها وتسكين المستوطنين
فيها واعاده ضم اجزاء من الاراضي
الفلسطينيين بعدها ضغطت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على الحكومه الاسرائيليه واوقفت
موضوع شرعنه البؤر الاستيطانيه على الاقل
لمده ثلاثه اشهر الان هذه المسيره وهذا
اليوم تاتي للضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مع ان جزء كبير من
الحكومه يشارك في المسيره ولكن للضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل اعاده النظر
في شرعنه هذه البؤره الاستيطانيه والسماح
للمستوطنين بالصعود والسكن على هذا الجبل
لمت
ابعه المروه البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات